[Music]
welcome to alpha the city of a thousand
planets
oh it's in you update us I'd be
delighted to the alpha station has grown
7% this year and since it left the
terrestrial orbit it has traveled almost
700 million miles population almost 30
million 3236 species from the four
corners of the universe live on board
pooling their knowledge and cultures
over 5000 languages spoken
not counting the various computer
languages demographics to the south are
the submerged parts with 800 species
living in all kinds of liquids such as
the peaceful Pollan farmers who grow
cobalt to the north we have gaseous
lands dominated by the Aegean low whose
extreme sensitivity makes them
specialists and neurosciences and
molecular components they can build
cells of any kind to the east of them
the large colony of analytes
they control information technology
finance and banking finally to the west
in a pressurized atmosphere we have 9
million humans and compatible species
home sweet home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the city of a thousand
planets
after centuries of peace and prosperity
an unknown force wants to destroy all we
have created
because valerian and Laura lein you have
less than 10 hours to find the threat
and eliminated
[Music]
history is on the monitor
[Music]
[Music]